In order for f of x equals a to the x, to exhibit exponential decay. A must lie
between 0 and 1, not including either of these numbers. When a is in this
interval, the value of the function is multiplied by a fraction each time x
increases. Making f of x get smaller and smaller. Let's experiment with this
for a second. Here we are, back in friendly old Desmos, and I've typed in the
general function that we've been talking about, f of x equals a to the x. I've
made a into a number that I can adjust by sliding this right here. Right now, a
is set to 1 and, as we calculated before, this is just a horizontal line, f of
x equals 1. Now, let's see what happens as I decrease a. You can see right
away, just when I let it go below 1, we already have a function showing
exponential decay. As I continue to make it smaller, the decay gets more and
more steep. It's happening more quickly. That's going to continue to happen
until a gets too small. When a reaches 0, we have that constant function again.
Except, this time, it's at f of x equals 0. We can, of course, also slide over
into the exponential growth area as well. That would just mean we need to
increase a past 1. Let's try that. Here were are back in our exponential decay.
And there we go, we're growing. Just above 1 we already see that new pattern
forming. And the growth gets steeper and steeper as a increases. Since we're
going to be multiplying by more and more each time x increases. If I let a get
really big, our graph's going to increase at incredibly quick rate. I would
encourage you to visit the Desmos website and play around with this on your
own. It's really fun to see how many different things you can do with
exponential functions.